well obviously the starting position is
a really really really tough one and I
did terribly in the opening I was always
losing my games in the opening because I
did things wrong see one of the things I
thought I was the general of my army
right I'm responsible for my decisions
and I figured that my rooks were kind of
like cannons and my Knights were like
the cavalry the bishop was my Archer and
my queen well she was just wonderful
she's like a tank she could just go all
over the place so I often opened with
this move which is a terrible opening
move because I was thinking I should get
my cannons into play right away my
opponent would oftentimes play d5
anticipating my move Hyland during my
route the bishop just takes it so that
was a disturbing development that I just
lost my rook you remember what I did I
remember what I did next the exact same
thing and he took both my rooks I mean
my opponent I know exactly I was so
terrible I just lost both rooks like
within sight of four moves and you know
I thought my opponent didn't miss a
trick boy he knew exactly what was going
on so my first experiments with chess
openings were terrible because I didn't
pay attention to the center so then I
started to pay attention to the center
and I discover
bird through a lot of chess friends who
helped me that there's all kinds of
names for chess openings and you know
what became my favorite chess opening
you ready for this one it's called the
fried liver attack you know that one
have you heard about the fried liver
attack I know I know and a fried liver
attack so what's that so the first thing
I when I started getting better at chess
the first thing I realized is that I've
got to play from the opening in what is
called the center so my opening would
move would be this move which is a very
good opening move because it occupies
the center and my opponents often played
the same because they were experienced
players too they didn't try to develop
their rooks they would play E 4 E 5 so
now I would bring out my cavalry Knight
f3 attacking his pawn on e5 with my
knight my opponent would defend the pawn
on e5 with knight c6 alright so yes
young man correct
that was the move I played now I would
bring out my Archer my bishop and the
bishop would come to see for this is
called the Italian opening so far so
good so all of these chess moves have
their own individual opening names so
the bishop comes to the square c4 and it
radiates danger against the pawn on f7
my opponents would play the move Knight
f6 attacking my pawn on e4 and this is
yes young men
correct this is where I would lunch an
attack okay it's very very early to
launch the attack but my thinking is
that my night
the cavalry combined with my the
strength of the archer my Bishop I'm
attacking the pawn on f7 my opponent to
block the threat would play d5 yes young
men it correct that would indeed be my
move
II takes d5 capturing upon and attacking
my opponents Knight now yes in there
that's right Knight takes d5 so this is
the starting position of one of my
favorite favorite positions in chess
when I was young was this position
because now yes young men that's the
fried liver attack Knight takes f7
attacking blacks Queen attacking blacks
rook
well black doesn't want to lose either
the queen or the rook so blacks King has
to capture White's Knight so now I've
lost a knight
yes young man what that's right this is
the fried liver attack Queen f3 check
now the Queen gives a check to the black
King but simultaneously it's a double
attack not only does the Queen attack
blacks King but the Queen also attacks
blacks Knight you see that the knight
and the bishop attack the knight the
Queen attacks the king and the knight so
black who's very very happy he's a
knight ahead he protects his knight King
to e6 oh I really like that black King
in the middle of the board so yes young
man what did I okay I could play that
would indeed be a check to Black's King
but blacks King would keep running away
and then my queen would be attacked by
this Bishop and I'm still a knight
behind so how else could I attack this
night young lady okay the problem is if
I capture the knight immediately Bishop
captures d5 black's queen is ready to
recapture my bishop now I left lost my
Archer yes young men well then he would
trade Queens so let's go back let's go
back for just a moment to this situation
because this is a crucial crucial
situation how could I put more pressure
on this night young man excellent bingo
Knight to c3 okay notice now I'm
attacking this Knight with this Knight
with this Bishop with this Queen the
King defends the knight and the Queen
defends the knight but that's only two
defenders and I've got three three
attackers yeah okay but this is the
fried liver attack now my opponents
would oftentimes retreat their night
with ninety seven protecting the night
oh oh now now what do I do
I've got to bring in more attackers
right but
how could I bring in more attackers what
should white do what can I do
yes young man okay I I brought my queen
out
I brought my bishop out and I brought my
night out so I've got three attackers in
the game but all my other pieces and
pawns are on the original squares and
I've got to bring out more guys young
man what do you recommend it could be
why yes be two or even two oh that's
clever
I could play my pawn to be three and
move my Bishop to a3 with the idea of
capturing this night which is defending
this night that's a very yes once I
capture that night I'd be attacking the
Queen so this is a very clever move and
not bad I'll have to think about that
probably what blackest is intending to
do is he's intending to defend his night
with his pawn and then try to run away
he's going to try to run away so while
b3 is an interesting and maybe even a
very clever move White has a better
choice
what could white do that's better than
b3 ah young man
that's like what I try to do with my
rook to bring my rook into the game yeah
that's a good move but remember that in
the opening what we're trying to do is
play in the center we're trying to
always play in the center so white
should make a move that plays into the
center young man what would you do
precisely d4
now remember this pawn on e5 helps
shelter or protect the black King right
so with this Bodie for white is trying
to attack this pawn on e5 and get that
pawn shield out of the way young man
what do you think okay for black now
okay take the knight it's blacks turn
this knight can't move yeah
now the gentleman back there said b3
with the idea of taking this Knight
well b3 with the idea of Bishop here and
taking this Knight well with this move
d4 you introduce the idea of Bishop g5
with a similar idea to attack that night
and by the way on g5 the bishop would be
pinning now my opponents oftentimes took
my pawn okay now how could white win
back his knight yeah young man young man
how
Queen e2 is a check that's not a bad
move but when you play Queen to e2
you're no longer attacking this knight
on e4 where else could you move with the
Queen yes that's the move Queen efore
check uh-oh
the black king is in trouble right yeah
well whites go in this position is to
try to regain the night that he
sacrificed so the king is in check let's
say the King moves here now what do you
do yes young man what do you do yes okay
we'll come back to this position and
yeah because don't forget this pawn is
attacking your knight so if you take my
knight I'll take your knight but the
better move and you made the right one
was to play Knight takes okay now you've
won you back your knight and look look
at blacks King it's in trouble right
let's say black captures the knight
young man in the back yes
correct very very powerful move King has
to come back and now what do you do oh
dear
young man what do you do Queen dee
fighters
Queen to e5 check that's a good move no
you don't like that move what do you
what move do you like right remember
what we were saying we want to bring out
more of our pieces in in chess parlance
we say that at the starting position all
of our pieces are in the hospital
they're recut recuperating so when we
bring our pieces off the back rank we
bring them in to attack they leave the
hospital and Bishop to g5 check is an
excellent move oh my gosh
where can that black King go only one
square
what do you say that's a good move
that's a good move there's a better one
whoops that's correct that's a checkmate
you could capture the queen with the
Queen does anybody see a second
checkmate yes
so White has a choice he could take the
Queen or thanks to our Bishop take the
king here we go we're going to go back
to this position for now do you remember
when we took the knight okay we had this
position we had we started from this
position oh and the young man played the
brilliant move Queen to e4 check
attacking the king the King stepped here
and then you recommended Knight takes d5
which is the excellent move now instead
of capturing the knight Knight takes d5
I'm going to play for black King c5 the
King is out to c5 that Kings been
running hasn't it now let's try to
understand blacks motivation he wants to
take our Bishop and he wants to take our
Knight
so we've got two pieces not just one but
two pieces on pre what should we do what
should we do what do you think
move to b3 okay after Bishop b3 I'll
lose my night okay but then black would
recapture with his queen Bishop takes
Queen tix and then the King and blacks
King is perfectly safe ah well he has
two rooks and black is a merge with an
extra Bishop Oh
back back back we'll come back to this
position okay
so now we have to figure out a really
tricky move oops that's the wrong one I
wanted to go King to c5 okay young lady
what would you do B 2 2 B 3 now let's
understand the motivation behind the
move b2 b3 first of all we protect our
Bishop that's okay and secondly like
that young gentleman there we do have
the idea of developing our Bishop with a
check but let's say black captures our
Knight
oh dear oh dear yes yeah yes
in the blue yes you what would you do
now
yeah well if we capture Queen takes d5
Queen takes d5 black surviving black
surviving what yes but all we
successfully did was trade bishops after
b2 b3 I think the young lady had a
different idea in mind I think her idea
was in this position to give you a check
check I think that was her idea whew
that was like were you thinking about
that one too but now the king could drop
back the bishop captures the knight
that's a check that after Queen takes
white still stymied darn it yes what
would you do
ah but don't forget that he will capture
our queen how about Queen here check
that's fine
Queenie a check but what happens after
Bishop here how many would like to take
the rook would you like it would you
like to take the rook yes so you took
the rook yay you took the rook now let's
have a consideration let's think about
this for a second
we just want a rook which was pretty
good right and it would be terrible if
this rook were to capture this Queen ah
you don't want that to happen but
fortunately for us the rook can't
capture the Queen because the bishops in
the way oh yes young man no it's black
to move blacks turn it's blacks turn yes
young man
Bishop before check whew that's just a
second that's devastating because the
bishop attacks the King and makes a
discovered attack against the Queen so
even if we take the bishop that it takes
the Queen you don't like that so let's
go back see this is this is what I did
when I was a kid is I'd love to look at
the fried whoops I love
I'd love to analyze the fried liver
attack with blacks King marching all
over the board so we had this situation
a moment ago and the night is here and
black played the move King here and we
just saw a line with the move b3 and
that didn't work out so well for white
it wasn't like the best thing what would
you do young man
b4 check ok that's check I can't take
the pawn because it's the knight is
protecting the pawn that's correct but
what's protecting the bishop King takes
hold it hold it don't say boo don't say
boo just yet hey don't say foo just what
well if we move our queen to e to check
nothing protects the night but look at
that King that King is out there
marching around the board do we have
another check
I'll give you yes night two III check ah
okay now we take the pawn now look at
that King look at that King it went all
the way up the board now remember what I
was saying about bringing more attackers
into the game you've got to bring your
pieces out of the hospital and into the
game young man Bishop d2 is a good move
it's a good move that's a check okay but
what else could we do with check to
bring young man in the back yes yes
that's okay but we need to bring our
pieces into the game young man correct
rook the one check oh my oh my now let's
say black if you move this King here
then your Bishop d2 check is mate let's
just see that on the board thanks to the
rook covering this square the King can't
go this pawn is protected so how about
King here
Knight to c4 check is one move
is there another move that we can check
remember to bring our pieces into the
game correct
now let's say the black King runs here
young man queen d3 check is very very
good Queen d3 check is very good
nada Lena what yes you're right
take the pawn with the Queen yes Queen
takes b5 checkmate thanks to the rook oh
but this McQueen is even stronger yes
you know oh I sure did I took it in on
three vias variation I forgot to put it
back so that was really really good
let's do it again
let's go back back back to this position
remember you guys played this great move
Knight III check and King takes allowed
our rook into the game King here now
we're not doing it very well
Queen check isn't so good Queen check
isn't so good we got to bring more
pieces and pawns into the attack what
else could white do how else could white
use other people who aren't developed
and bring those into the game yes young
man what would you do Oh bravo Bravo a
four check that's a good move now we've
seen that King takes before hasn't
worked King takes before hasn't
so let's say King here Wow okay how many
like b5 check you don't have many
supporters on this one after b5 check
the king could move here what now other
pawn to a5 is a check that would make us
come over and it's checkmate
how about King here Roy that black King
sure is elusive
ah now you're getting the idea
developing your pieces with Czech king
cakes young man ah but your queen has
already developed so now I'm going to
run away Don did that deficit what would
you like to play rook b1 check oh dear
that's a tough one here I'm afraid I
can't go here I can't go here I can't go
here I can't go here if I go here I'm
afraid you're going to go Queen here so
I'll go King here
you guys are doing really good so far
young man what would you do Bishop takes
eise evan is a move the reason that you
would do that is because you're afraid
he's going to take your bishop
right so after Bishop takes eise Evan
Bishop takes Issa don't take that night
you need that bishop right now okay but
your looks already develop you don't
want to under develop your rook what
about you young man what would you do
Knight c4 that's an interesting move
probably a very good one in fact maybe
after Knight c4 I'd have to move my
knight here so another move you know
rook rook b4 check
that's an interesting move but can I
take your bishop
oh I'm losing all the visas we don't
want to go too far overboard okay here
I'm looking for a move with the Queen
I'm looking for a move with the Queen to
set up a checkmate young man is that
what you wanted to say as well yeah
Queen d3 so now you're threatening okay
let me let me protect this square I'm
afraid of that squirt let me play here
what would you do so I was if I was
trying to protect against this and
against this sorry yes if I go Queen b5
the Queen will trade well the Queen will
capture if I go Queen b3 the Queen will
capture young lady what did you want to
do rook to where Knight takes d5 very
good and after Knight takes d5 ah now
what are we gonna do with white what do
you think this is really good it wasn't
as good good here white can do something
really devastating what do you think
you're man correct
Queen b5 check the King can't capture
the Queen thanks to the rook so King
takes now pause pause pause how many
ways can white checkmate in one move no
count count the number of checkmates
that you see in the position you see one
that's good
you see two does everybody else see -
okay what's one of them what's one of
the check needs that's checkmate number
one okay you see how that's checkmate
okay what
checkmate number two young man rook a1
that's correct so there's two checkmates
in that position let's go back and see
how this all happened
you started with check which is
excellent that is excellent you captured
the bishop you went check which is
excellent we can't take the pawn because
we saw one variation you went here
that's excellent
this was a great move check now I played
this move and b5 check was played is
there a better move for white how could
white play and checkmate in two moves
correct and King here and now young men
now remember before you wanted to play
Queen b5 and I took it
now with the font on a4 it's checkmate
okay you guys did really good on that
one now I'm going to trick you
yeah you ready you ready King here and
gone all say it once but White has
checkmate in two moves how can he do it
do you see the checkmate in two moves
young man okay how does that make a
checkmate after say a fight so blacks
King wants to run away ah checkmate in
two moves this is a tricky one
no you're not ready how about you young
man what do you 95 check would be
excellent except for one small tiny
detail can the knight be captured uh-huh
that's us right that's a that's so okay
we're looking for checkmate in two come
on guys and girls you can do it huh
young lady Knight to c4 check how many
checks does white have in the position
white could play Queen here check but
that would be bad white could take this
pawn with check well that would be bad
too white could play Queen here check
but that would be bad white could play
Queen here check well that would be bad
so Knight c4 check you wanted to move
the knight you just chose the wrong
school
err now black-skinned can't go here here
here only move young be my checkmate
isn't that do you guys have you seen
this pattern before where were the night
and just two pawns checkmated the King
on the side that's pretty cool isn't it
ah you don't see that every day so this
is what I did when I was a kid I liked I
liked the fried liver attack and I just
I just thought it was the most wonderful
thing in the world and I loved trying to
hunt down blacks King let's go back for
a second let's go back for a second now
you did you guys enjoy being the
attacker yeah that was fun
but being the defender isn't always that
much fun one of the things that kind of
stopped me from playing the fried liver
attack is called the wilts bar
counter-attack ah how does that work
okay let's get to our position efore 'if
I've I develop my knight he develops his
knight I develop my Archer he develops
his Knight I go here and my opponent
he's such a turkey he doesn't see my
threat to take my his pawn he went here
bringing out his Archer yes young men
what would you do with white knight
takes f7 excellent not only winning upon
right but also attacking blacks queen
and attacking blacks rook
devastating right blacks devastated but
my opponents would trick me you know how
you know what they would do here what do
you think correct I would say hey wait a
minute I thought I was attacking you
with my devastating night now look at
this Bishop takes F to check and
suddenly I'm playing the role of the
defender what would you do what would
you do young man
King captures the bishop yay
so White's a bishop ahead do you know
what yes that's what I was thinking so
now black captures our pawn with check
oh I tell ya I was scared what do you
think I did what do you what would you
do with white would you move your King
would you move your knight is attacking
your King where are you gonna move the
King back correct but where where's back
this square this square this square or
should I come up
I shouldn't come up okay let's imagine
that we move the King back to this
square then what could black do the
queen is attacked so black has to move
his is Queen right what do you think
correct Queen h4 check let's imagine
that white blocks the check yes exactly
then the night takes oh my goodness
attacking the rook so let's say takes
Queen takes pawn check is good is there
something better young man queen takes
rook check that's pretty good now the
King has to protect the school clean the
King comes up now what what okay but
then you're trading a different trading
a passive piece that's in the hospital
all the way for a piece that's really
really active what's a better move than
trading Queen young man correct coup
come on clean g2 check King comes back
now remember what we were saying about
getting our pieces out of the hospital
okay
all of black's pieces only the Queen and
the knight are working what else how
else could we get our pieces out we're
just analyzed I'll play you guys play
black I'll play white now what would you
do if you had black in the
position young man queen efore check he
will block with his queen and protect
his bishop young man what did you think
yes that's an excellent move rook to f8
b because the knights going to take it
okay now imagine if this guy this Archer
this bishop could get in the game for
example in this position you could take
my pawn with check right how come you
didn't want to take the pawn with check
that's a real good move would you like
to take it okay
Queen takes g3 check and let's say the
King goes here it's check okay now
imagine you're your Bishop your
LightSquared Bishop could enter the game
where could it how could it attack
White's King young man
d5 is much more aggressive because with
the move d5 you attack the bishop and by
the way in this moment the knight is not
protected because the bishop is blocked
let's say white captures okay in this
position I'm going to say that there's a
mate in one two three four checkmate for
white and four moves young lady
excellent Bishop to h3 check remember
we're bringing our guys out of the
hospital into the light now that looks
really really strong what about this
move how
what's checkmate what what's blacks
checkmate after king e2 checkmate in one
young man what do you think correct you
see that lovely checkmate the Queen
covers the Queen covers the bishop
covers so let's say in this position the
white bishop comes back now how can you
checkmate in two young men what would
you do Queen takes G to check is correct
and now where's the checkmate young man
Queen f1 checkmate wow that was a
devastating counter-attack wasn't it yes
it was yes it was so the moral of this
story is be very careful